Gina Torres what can we talk about
serenity matrix all the different things
you've been involved that are geek stuff
but you're also doing a new show called
Pearson talked to me about that oh my
god this is a dream come true for me I'm
executive producing it as well not just
starring in it so I've gotten to to
really really involve myself in the
storytelling in the casting and help
take it in the direction that I feel is
important in a place that we want to go
in terms of the stories that we want to
tell and what's happening in our world
today and being a reflection of it you
know and also entertaining people at the
same time and bringing them in and
intriguing them so yeah Pearson is is on
us a Wednesday nights we're just getting
ready to stream our finale to have our
finale so but you can stream anytime so
please please please watch I think it's
great I'm a pundit of color so to see an
actress of color like I judge let alone
an active got an actress of color does
get many opportunities to lead a show to
executive produce it as well and you've
worked your tail off for numerous
decades to get in this position how much
of a joy is it for you to be able to
finally show what you can really do as a
lead it is joyous it's a little
overwhelming it's incredibly emotional
and I don't shy away from the
responsibility of it I mean I I do
understand that there's a great deal of
care and because people are looking as
are you you know people like star
community and Beyond are looking at well
what is she gonna do now that she's now
that she has a chance to do it what's
she gonna say I got a lot to say what's
the flavor yes you do you always that
yeah I know that I love that about you
always have Gina now you know you're
amongst all the nerd stuff here the geek
stuffs here huh this is this has really
been all your career I know
right there okay I just interviewed her
I just interviewed I'm trying not to
fall apart I mean Jamie Lee Curtis I
mean every cell of her body it's just
she is so extraordinarily and truly
authentically herself and that's all
that we could ever hope to to be to get
to that place I'd like to say that you
are Gina is you seem pretty real to me
you know um with now all these years
later serenity what's your feeling about
it what's your vibe which it has things
changed for you is you still in love
with it obviously haven't done it but
like how much more appreciation you have
for now you know at the time when you
when you're doing a show like that
you're blessed you feel blessed you're
happy that you get to work you're even
happier that you get to work with a
bunch of people that you like in the
respect and we did become a family and
we do still keep in touch you never ever
ever imagined that once you get canceled
that it will have a life beyond that and
we did I mean we just keep cheating
father time it's been 17 years since we
first shot a frame of that show and I
just did a convention in Philadelphia
and it is just as fresh it's just as
meaningful it is just as a place to be
and live and experience as it was back
then and even more so I mean there there
are kids that are younger than whose
parents have introduced them to it that
are you know that they've been alive
less time than we've been off the air
and so that's saying something let's say
it's something about Johnson his vision
and and the work that we did you're in
the echelon of Star Trek and Star Wars
passed on generation to generation and
that's a positive rep up one lesser
what's yeah I know I'm getting the notch
which I appreciate I respect it one is
there one franchise property that you
would love to get a shot at that you've
watched from a farm been like oh I could
kick ass in that right now it's
guardians of the galaxy oh yeah yeah
right thank you I do every day just you
know Black Panther where are you black
panther to come on there I mean the list
just keeps getting a little longer to
who would that hurt what else do you
need
Thank You Gina continued success